I love it boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation we have a super
exciting show on radical wholeness I'm
really excited to have Philips Shepard
joining us hello oh yeah greatly
appreciate it
Philips visiting us from Toronto to host
a workshop which he hosts around the
world on radical wholeness and on just
this major transition that's going on in
society were figuring out how to drop
out of our heads that culture programs
us to be in our heads and into our
bodies and so we're gonna explore this
together we have you know a two-time
author on our hands we have initially
authored new self new world and that was
in 2010 and then now the author of
radical wholeness which came out one
year ago about almost to the day almost
the day and also obviously we teaching
the workshops as well as teaching
facilitators around the world which is
really exciting on on something that's
becoming super main is getting to become
more mainstream it's not like you know
the mainstream media outlets aren't
picking it up quite yet but we do have
gotta come it's gonna come yeah so well
okay as we're gonna drop into radical
wholeness we're gonna drop into what
you're teaching and how but we want to
know how you got here you know who are
you
how'd you get here let's talk about that
okay to talk about that we need to talk
about Phillip Sheppard the teenager yeah
and I felt suffocated by my culture it's
like the adults around me we're living
out this fantasy and no one seemed to
realize it and they're all stuck in
these patterns of behavior that are like
shallow and and repetitive and and I I I
it was like the warrior spirit
against against this stuff just you know
give me a pattern and I will demolish it
how are you well you know what do you
mean by that question is this is this an
ontological inquiry so I was intolerable
as a teenager but but what but what I
realized is that I wasn't going to win
like it's like fighting an unknown
assailant but cuz your cultures
everywhere in your own body right and
and so the only the only way I was gonna
survive and not succumb was to leave my
culture so I went to England and I
bought a bicycle was this around
eighteen or one was it I was 18 okay
went to England when I was 18 bottom
bicycle and headed for Japan so high you
know you know normal story here yeah
that's why I you know alone through
Europe and Middle East and India and
Japan oh I spent you know and I slept
outside everywhere and I there's
something when your life depends on it
this whole new field of sensitivity
awakens so you know I'd be cycling along
and the Sun would be going down and I'd
start to attune need to find a place to
sleep and it was it was like every night
I was guided to a place where I could
spend the night safely mm-hmm and I went
through so many different ways of
understanding what it means to be human
yeah and when you run a bike I mean I'm
a kid on a bike right and you just feel
everything it just sits through you and
every one of those cultures was luminous
and beautiful and everyone was limited
but the only time there was only one
psyche I got hit with culture shock and
that's when I came home yeah and it's
like what is this bizarre world and so
that that time away I was away for two
years
I I gained the ability to question my
culture yeah and not only that but the
reason I went to Japan was to study
classical Japanese noh theater Japanese
no it's called Japanese no feel like an
orc ano w and oh I know it's what they
call no gakuto no and what is this why
do you have to study that why not so
when I was when I was 17
like I I was an actor working with a
company downtown and and I was reading
everything so I read these treatises on
classical no theater when I say
classical no theater it's from the time
of Chaucer so much 1300 1300 so 600
years old yeah yeah
but this guy the founder of noh theater
is a MIMO Tokyo was saying like in
allegory and illusion everything that
could be said about art I was like
charged by this and then a noh theater
play was coming to Montreal which is
which is a five hour bus ride from where
I was living in Toronto so I went to see
this play and it shook me to my core it
just undid my being I end and so I was
in tears shaking to my core and I had no
idea how did had that effect on me and
so it was in Japan that I studied no
theater and discovered Hara Hara is the
Japanese word for belly for oh yeah
because that's horoho Chi boo there you
go yeah
they're good until your 80% full yeah
yeah so so if the Japanese culture like
you can't really translate hata as belly
because you know in the West bellies
what this troublesome area that's prone
to in digestion and weight gain and
embarrassment or if you work really hard
vanity our relationship with the valley
precludes us from translating Hara as
belly in in the Japanese culture Hara is
where your profoundest truth lies Oh
interesting
it's like when you come home to yourself
that's where you come to
and so that's why I'm watching this
Japanese play as a teenager and I have
no idea the effect it's having on me
because because like I'd never seen an
arm lift from that place I've never seen
a head turn and see from that place yeah
yeah so I I mean I was so blessed as a
teenager to encounter that and that sort
of started a really deep journey for me
and you saw in your childhood you were
seeing a lot of this sort of meaningless
connections these surface-level
connections that were you wanted to
shatter through them you were like what
is the human experience it's way more
than what I see here and I want to get
to that and then you got to it by going
and seeing this no theatre and then and
then you how did you how did you make
the connection that that they do that
the Hara is the gut do you have to be in
Japan till I get that part of it and
yeah I didn't know about it till I was
there and I studied it and there's you
know there is is like the the basis of
the Performing Arts in Japan it's like
that's where you go to and and you know
even in South that's where you go to is
that place in the body and we're you
know we're up up in in the head trying
to all the time I think you're
everything I just slowly dropped a
little bit more into my body and it
started feeling really good yeah yeah
whoa they're not calling the gut like
second brain so much so many neurons or
Seattle I mean anatomically there I mean
that's what's interesting
anatomically there's a brain in the
belly yeah and you look at you look at
our culture this was discovered like in
the early 1900s there was a book
published in 1910 by Byron Robinson at
his Chicago the MIS anatomist
and he a post his book called the
abdominal and pelvic brain interesting
and he had the anatomical drawings
mapped out the neurology and it's like
we forgot about it
mm-hmm and then it was discovered again
by Johannes Langley we forgot about it
was discovered again in the 1960s by
Michael Gerson he's studying you know
the the gut and he's finding Sarah
Oh in there yeah which is a which is a
thought molecule what's it doing in the
gut and he discovered but even then it
took him 15 years to persuade his fellow
neuroscientists that this is by any
standard you wish to hold up a brain
okay so there is no place in our culture
story of what it means to be human for a
brain than the gut because that the head
is where the brain is the head should be
in charge we're totally totally devoted
to that I love how the story is emerging
for me I'm putting your pieces together
the early ones so so you have like
you're around 20 in Japan and you're
getting this Eureka moment of your
existence you're like okay if we at
least focus more on the body we can live
more fully rather than in our heads and
and then what what were the other things
that led you to be like I know how to
bring that to the world I've been an
actor all my life you started acting I I
would I've been an actor since teen my
team that explains the ability to yeah
how you really like you know you're just
like screw all this cultural oh yeah oh
yeah so so here's an interesting thing
any exercise you give an actor that is
worth anything is another way to learn
to be present hmm it's that simple right
if you can go onstage and be present to
what is happening with the whole of your
being everyone will watch they will
understand yeah it's just it's just a
given so you know as an actor I had to
get into my body or I was wouldn't I had
to learn how to drop the breath into the
whole of my body or my voice wouldn't
carry and and and and so I'm as an actor
I've watched hundreds of hours of
classical no theatre and taken that into
my body and I'm training in western
theatre and taking that in my body and
I'm sort of finding this marriage
between
the two so so I ran my own there were
three directors of this
interdisciplinary theater company one
was a dancer a mime and I was an actor
and we trained each other and and back
in Toronto back in trial it was called
physical theater before they're like in
1983 before there was such a thing as on
recalled physical theater and then I
hooked up with a guy Stephen Rumble Oh
who was one of the pioneers of physical
theater in England and he ran a theater
called triple action theater and I
trained with him and he's he's radical
and eventually you you a - you know you
step on stage as an actor and you attune
to the life that is there and you ride
it the way a surfer rides away and and
so ya know stepping out of the puppetry
and into the life of it and I was I was
teaching workshops for actors that were
were you know trying to bring them into
an awareness of the Lai's of the body of
the you know that deep awareness in the
Gothic centre from which you see and
hear and speak and so my acting
workshops were unlike anything else and
I noticed a lot of people are coming to
the acting workshop who weren't actors
like graphic designers and philosophy
students and and what happened was
working with them things deepened for me
in questions deepened and that led to my
first book so my first book new self new
world grew out of that material and in
fact when I began writing the book it
was called
way of the actor and now I gave that up
I mean it took me 10 years to write the
book and I I started it from scratch
four times yeah and and was on this
learning curve
I just loved every minute of it okay
before we do a new self new world now
now how did how does one study like what
did you learn in no theater that then
brought you into the ability to to learn
how to act
and also from the body and also learn
how to teach other people how to act so
here's a contrast between no theatre and
Western okay yeah in western theatre
it's all what what happens what's
important is all from the waist up you
know there's this happening and and and
it's from the waist up in no theatre the
power of the performance is from the
waist down now that's hard this is the
subtle opening of the leg as you walk in
and directly they have a sensitivity to
the earth that no interesting that it
just shimmers and they defeat slide
along the stage and the whole body is
attuned to the earth and the leg lifts
and stamps and it's just a milked up so
they've got this principle like the
actor's body in no theater on the way
stop it's open and available and soft
from the waist down it's grounded and
strong
yeah and that availability up above I
mean we cram the body with congestion
and anxiety and and it's such we so I've
come to understand that any energy that
is held in the body is a form of
resistance to the present so that
wide-open availability of the body with
that groundedness of the legs and the
hips below it is a dynamic that were
let's what our true intelligence is can
we can we segue into that yes I have to
I have to still under your you're on a
whole nother level of being in
consciousness so we have to see you have
to keep them back this is insane so this
is this is about the the connectedness
of of the body to the earth to the point
where I as you were speaking first of
all I had this like really interesting
distinction between like Western I guess
culture and acting where it's like you
know it's kind of like heady or like
trying to like move upper body like you
were describing and then this for some
reason I was imagining this you know the
lower body was you know just like you
said sliding and then up and then this
very strong and I was imagining the the
the Earth's energy coming through my
legs from my feet being planted on the
ground and actually being aware of that
process yeah and and what that does it
gives you a whole deeper sense of
connection to earth which gives you a
deeper sense of connection to the
audience and the life that you're
bringing through you and so anyway I'm
just so interested about that at least
to start that like because that that
totally give it gets me gets me going
for everything else that we're we're
getting into so cool in our culture our
legs our prosthetics mmm basically
that's how we treat them that's how we
experience to take the brain places yeah
yeah yeah and and and the legs are
teeming with intelligence yes yes and
sensitivity they feel the world they
feel the earth and and they just
perambulate like prosthetics there's a
the the earliest lyric poet in the
Western tradition and lyric poetry is
uses I epic poetry uses they so the
earliest lyric poet was a guy called
Arco locust and he was he was this
mercenary soldier who wrote with passion
and and he he wrote this little fragment
of a poem
with what springs in my legs I left the
rocks I just you know that embodied
connection with that intelligence and
and and I had to reclaim that for my SIA
and I had to reclaim their spaciousness
in the body because because so can I say
go into intelligence yes and I will
never think of my bottoms of my feet in
my legs the same after this I won't I
will never think of it the same I will
always be much more aware of what the
intelligence lies and the legs and what
comes up through the body from the legs
I love that I'm so happy that you taught
us that that's really beautiful
so intelligence we've defined
intelligence as the ability to reason in
an abstract fashion now we've given you
know we've given that definition to the
part of us that happens to excel at
reasoning in an abstract so it's a
somewhat flattering definition for
anyone who lives in their heads but it's
it's nonsense but and and you know they
give you an IQ test that's the faculty
there they're testing for and here's the
number that's your intelligence our
intelligence I mean that's a form of
intelligence it's your this one
bandwidth on the spectrum but the
spectrum I would begin by calling
sensitivity so you can have a
sensitivity to language to a child's
tears to arithmetic relationship to
color to music that I mean you there are
there are innumerable sensitivities you
can't couldn't possibly name them all
any sensitivity it's like a sensitivity
is it's like a sensitivity towards a
field of knowledge kind of it you're
being a sensitivity is something that
allows you to be informed
yeah yeah right by this color by this
music by this whatever it is and then
some of us have have trained ourselves
to be more sensitive to yeah I think I
think some of us are just born with this
this depth of sensitivity you know in a
really specialized area yeah but the
thing with sensitivity is that it's
reactive so the retina reacts to light
if it didn't we wouldn't see that
reactivity needs to be grounded and that
doesn't happen without the body so I
think our true intelligence is grounded
sensitivity huh that's good right yeah
and that's good and you take that okay
if you accept that that our true
intelligence is grounded sensitivity
then you look at our education system
which systematically desensitizes us and
leaves us chronically ungrounded and you
know it's doing that in the name of
supporting and promoting our
intelligence so we mistake cleverness
for intelligence and we're super clever
and we're just astonishing yeah clever
but but we've forgotten how to live
intelligent Lee yeah as a culture
grounded sensitivity yeah and you know
you we mistake cleverness for
intelligence and also some people
mistake luck for intelligence and
there's also some very I don't I don't
like calling anybody dumb or ignorant or
whatever but why is it that like the
people that are just lacking a certain
sense of intelligence think they're so
terribly smart and they they just
discredit anybody they don't it has
something you know that makes sense once
that you know somebody says something
that makes sense and and and just the
dumbest among us just discredit these
people so that's that's what I'm
troubled with that's all in well I
appreciate I appreciate your troubled
State and just to throw something in
there for my money the most dangerous
people in the world who feel their ideas
about the present more keenly than they
feel
present Oh interesting I don't think
anything that's work that's pretty good
Ron I like that one there's many
dangerous people in power making
decisions on our behalf that are
extremely problematic but that's a Purdy
yes that's a pretty good way to
summarize though it's people that are
intellectualizing about the present and
trying to make decisions for other
people about the present but they're the
least grounded you in the present the
ones that have the most grounded
sensitivity in the present that's like
the most year that's the best currency
to have as a human as your ability to be
grounded sensitive in the present and
then be able to be there with other
people with that loving kindness
gratitude energy that other people just
vibe off of and they're like I can't
even be mad around this person yeah so
then you go back to no theater so here's
this lower part of the body in contact
with the earth and grounded and humming
with that and the upper body available
and open
there's the grounded sensitivity and we
walk around with this cluster of
congested energy in our bodies and we
sew so our culture is attached to the
idea that we are alone and it's like
it's like when we're kids were taken as
seedlings and stuck into this pot of
Alumnus and said grow there that's what
we're told right if you if you accept if
you take on that cultural instruction
that you're alone then there's this
cascade of effects that starts to happen
to begin with you
you experience your private feelings and
and thoughts as strictly private your
experience is a private experience and
it's sort of held by this boundary and
then the world is out there if and of
course any experience is shared a
heartbeat is felt in those around you
there's there's
thing that happens in the body that
doesn't ripple into the world but if
you're attached to the idea that your
experience is private your primary job
in life becomes to manage that
experience so it feels good so it's
successful if you're if that's your
primary job in life then your primary
relationship is with yourself and then
you are trapped in self-consciousness
and you see that I mean in these OLS
yeah well-intentioned movements that
that put you know put the attention on
the self and fix the self and feel your
breath and like whether it's new age
your body working whatever and that's
all fine I have nothing against that but
that's that's just the precondition to
opening up to the world yes yes so it's
so but it's an S is it it's a necessary
step to be able to tune in word to be
able to break off break break through
the barrier of I am alone and that I'm
actually interconnected I think it's a
misunderstood step that's all so so
here's my take on it the body is a
resonator the body will resonate to the
present it will resonate to every
current that is passing through the
world but what we do is we we stuff the
body full of cotton balls like a bell
and then you know the presents going
like this trying to ring it oh that's a
good way to put it right and it's like a
heart like a heartbeat literally yeah
yeah so if you if you're really in tune
to existence you can feel your heart
beat and give your body life moment
after moment if you're real and that's
cascading into everything and that you I
like how you put that you if you put all
the cotton balls inside you and you try
and hear a heartbeat you can't so yeah
so interesting so we're trying to dig
cotton balls out and reprogram because
culture has made yeah the bit the
programming when you when you you know
do that inner work
for me the purpose of the inner work is
just to find and integrate the
obstructions mm-hmm right and you find
those in the integrative and there's
more and more space inside the body and
then the heartbeat that you wring to is
like the pulse of the present and there
is there's no hunter-gatherer culture
that has not achieved to the present and
felt it in ways we have no idea about
yeah they can feel animals moving
through the jungle they feel the
presence of water when they're thirsty
yeah they feel this this plant as a
medicinal plant and I mean we've got
this bizarre notion that that oh yeah
isn't it great those traditional
societies have have such a wonderful
knowledge of medicinal plants and of
course they would you know trial and
error over hundreds of years you you get
to know what's what trial and error that
that's that's insane I mean can you
imagine John's got a headache what plant
haven't we tried for headache oh here's
one here John try this oh no John died
is there anyone else who has a headache
because we've got another 47 plants to
try it's it's insane
they commune with the plants they feel
the life of that plant and understand
it's what they need at the moment over
and over and over the world the world is
whispering to us and we were stuffed
with cotton balls and don't don't hear
it in fact we're so stuffed with cotton
balls that the present ceases to exist
as a whole for us we've shattered that
reality though the one reality is
wholeness everything that it ends on
everything everything relies on
everything yeah it's just it's the
nature of our reality and we have so
desensitized ourselves as a culture that
we are we are numb to wholeness we can
you know when's the last time you felt
the present as a whole you
body as a whole or your life as a whole
it's it's we feel bits and pieces we we
aggregate them together but that's not
that's not homeless
wholeness doesn't have a boundary we
want to stuff the self into the
boundaries of wholeness in our culture
you know we aspire to be whole in body
mind and spirit and it's such a lovely
sentiment but it's nonsense because it's
saying you know there are these three
aspects to the self and you just need to
allow each of them to flourish and come
into harmony and you will be whole and
wholeness is found in your relationship
with the present in your relationship
with the world and we go digging down
inside ourselves to find wholeness and
it's not there and self-knowledge isn't
there we think self-knowledge is
something you find by reaching inside
self-knowledge is born in us by
relationship so you you see a kid
playing with chalk on a sidewalk and you
feel that moment and you're illuminated
by it in a certain way or you see a tree
and it suddenly catches you and you feel
that towering life and it's deep roots
and you're illuminated by it and the
more deeply you come in to felt
relationship with the world the more
deeply you discover yourself yes felt
relationship with the world our ability
to be present radically whole present
that is what our presence with the world
makes us radically whole yeah okay
interesting interesting that because
that I want to ask you a couple things
because you know you just went and you
know gave us the radical wholeness of
mission which is amazing you're talking
about the cotton balls being stuffed in
even before that you were mentioning the
hunter-gatherers just just the amount of
grounded sensitivity is amazing to think
about and even you know for people in
that were in the village that were in
the village in the marketplaces in the
village
with the kids in the village working on
the different aspects that needed to be
done there
just the sense of again I don't know I
romanticize many times the past because
I feel as though there was a there were
we had a better grasp on presence
because we were a little bit more
attuned to the being right there in the
present and that making us whole but I
want I want to know your thoughts about
there's cotton balls stuffed in from
from childhood first of all for the
adults how do we dig cotton balls how do
we practice the press had we practice
that presence you know you have
exercises that getting to cotton balls
out and then also what would be the
guidelines like app for kids like
they're you know they're a lot of their
neural architectures developed by their
time they're two or three and then
there's process of pruning throughout
life what do you think about the
education of a child and how we can
connect them to that that sense of
presence and learning the thing about
kids is that they learn how to be human
from the people around them so I don't
care what you're telling your kid as a
parent what you're modeling is what
they're learning
yeah right I mean you can yell at your
kids to settle down and what they will
see is power is achieved through through
anger and and aggression don't do as I
do do as I say that's it so then so then
there's this onus of responsibility on a
parent how to be fully present at your
child now if you're fully present your
child you will
understand their different harmony you
will understand that their soul aches to
explore and find out and and and then
well you know you unleash that on the
world and they're they're going great
guns but we instead we Corral kids into
a I mean think think of how many hours
as a kid you spend sitting in a chair at
a desk suppressing the body's energy
which which which is the body's
intelligence mmm-hmm right and and
filling your head with ideas and what
you learn the primary lesson that school
teaches our children is to divide their
thinking from their being and that is
that is the wound that runs through the
whole of our culture so we learn think
that we can think more clearly with this
segregated portion of our intelligence
than we can with the whole of our being
and how to access that
humming intelligence of the whole and
reconcile you know we live in this
binary culture or it's either this or
that like it's either you know you feel
from the heart or you you think
analytically but they don't belong
together we don't know how to integrate
them we've got these gut instincts and
we don't know how to integrate that with
the head or the head with the the gut
it's it's everything is
compartmentalized so you look at our
architecture any building we build is a
is a ultimately a symbol of what it
means to be human every aspect of our
culture symbolizes what it means to be
human so we build these houses that have
really clear lot lines and you need a
surveyor because you don't want to lose
one inch of your property and then the
houses is set safely back from the lock
line so you don't have to interact with
your neighbor and then your houses got
locks on all the windows and doors and
the inside of the house is
compartmentalized with doors that close
and lock and and that's our body that's
how we live in our body that's why we
feel so comfortable in that architecture
damn right and there are I mean again
good go to Japan and I remember as I was
taking I was I was riding all day it was
cold and raining and I I pulled up it
you know with my little youth hostel
book cuz there was a youth hostel here
and I couldn't find it and someone was
walking on the sidewalk can I help you
yes where is this place oh it doesn't
exist yeah great but and they took me
into their home right and they pull out
these paper screens to create the room
for me and put down the you know the
futon on the tatami and and and the
house is permeable won one room moves
into another you know there's this
permeability not just within the house
but between the house and the outside
yeah and we we have this thing we've
we've inculcated on impermeability to
our bodies
by contrast there's an African culture
the Anglo FA and and anthropologists
have remarked at their radical
indeterminacy of personality
mmm radical in diversity of person as in
I belong to the collective there isn't
like that there is it and it's part of
that but it's partly I'm I'm available
to the present the present will reveal
Who I am as I come into relationship
with the present this not arresting and
I'm that now and I'm used by the
president and and we we've we feel it's
our it's like our civic duty to
construct the structure of our
personality so that so that you
establish who you are and you know who
you are and for me you've got it you got
a choice you you can be who you know you
yourself to be or you can be present but
they're incompatible
the more strictly you hold on to your
built structured identity the less
available you are to the president
interesting yet that that for sure seems
to resonate with me because I'm I'm
thinking about how often I am feeling
how often I am open-minded and the more
that I am permeable that I'm in prayer
that I'm present that I'm open-minded
that I have greater connection to what
is going on around me that tree makes a
beautiful impression on me feeling on me
the person that is you know just kindly
doing something or even the loud person
makes an impression on me on the inside
of my god those it was loud and so I
feel that more so when I'm trapped in my
own like thinking processes I'm missing
on that that those feelings and those
sensitivities the way you've described
the house was so interesting the locked
nests of everything and inches on the
yards and the windows there and look at
a skyscraper what does a skyscraper tell
you the primary message it communicates
is that nature is irrelevant that's what
it's announcing to the world of
monolithic one yeah yeah yeah and and
like like a bit of moss is a taint on
the skyscraper and if there's a if
there's a plant it's whoa it's because
we've designed it and it's decoration
I mean we've turned the most intimate
teacher we have nature and turn it into
decoration and we're so clever yeah wow
that's a really interesting way to put
it just even having our you know our
plants in the studio to you know to me I
couldn't have I couldn't I could not
have them in the studio and it's not
because it's a decoration it's more like
I would be too far separated from Earth
and then that's companionship that's
something different interesting yeah I
you are you you're familiar with our
ecology architecture and ecology really
smash them together into our ecology and
there's beautiful buildings and
Singapore and other place in the world
where they've just done such a better
job at integrating earth into the
buildings yeah and yeah there's just
that's interesting two monolithic nasai
was a vertical forests vertical forests
yes so I'm I'm just I'm so that the
analogy of the body to the house and the
lockness you're talking about Japan
that's like kind of like these open its
modularity to the outside and to the
rooms and and and yeah and you look you
look at our primary cultural love affair
with the car the car is ahead on wheels
what three headlights would illuminate
the road better than two but but that's
intolerable we need the metaphor of the
two headlights because we have two eyes
interests right and we sweet we move
into the car the way we sit in our heads
and we listen to our private music and
podcasts the way we listen to our own
thoughts and we move through the world
and look at it through the windshield
like it can't touch us the way we sit
inside our heads and look out at the
world it's it's that's how we live in
our heads that's why we love the car so
much it just it's so cozily familiar
whoa yeah I don't whoa - headlights what
was the last time someone proposed like
a three headlight car
and and seen the efficacy of how well it
lights up the road I bet better of
course right so so why so what's its
because of the eyes right and you have
to when you're driving you have to see
the two eyes coming yeah this way the
two eyes going that way at the
taillights are the two eyes on the back
and then yeah the saltiness of the head
thank you Ron I wanna I want to talk
about the you you gave us the children
and you gave us the you know the
do be the role model for the kid don't
say be be that presence be that press
honestly as you can as honestly as you
can and admit the mistakes you know I
have so many and I really yeah it
exactly be as honest as I can I want to
know about the exercises that you teach
in your manifestos and in the in the
workshops digging the cotton balls out
burning throwing out a matter shooting a
flamethrower that there are there are so
many of them in the in the weekend
workshop the I moved through four themes
and the first theme is breath and that's
the morning of the first day and rest is
the second theme receptivity is the
third and integration is the fourth so
breath we're looking for the right way
to breathe there isn't such a thing
right so but there's a principle and the
principle is is the whole of your body
available to the back I mean to the
breath I was thinking about the back and
then you you begin to see how the breath
is shut down in the body we because like
breath is so shallow
almost all the time we muscle it we
think we need to muscle the breath and
we know yeah it's it's important to
breathe deeply and we are such a
top-down culture we push the breath down
from the top as deep as we can and that
takes muscles and the muscles get tired
and the breath goes shallow again and
that's not that's not how babies breathe
yeah so so the body releases to the
breath mmm and that's where the pelvic
ball comes in which in our culture is
shrouded in this shadow of neglect but I
feel like within the pelvic Bowl I feel
the pelvic floor as the ground of my be
the pelvic floor technically is a
diaphragm in the body so there's the
thoracic diaphragm and and a diaphragm
here the pelvic floor is a diaphragm
now the pelvic floor will support the
out-breath and release to the in-breath
but we've in our culture we tend to lock
it up we dead that area and when you
dead in that area when the breath is is
incapable of penetrating the pelvic Bowl
if the pelvic floor is the ground of
your being you have no place to land in
the body because it's in shadow it's in
darkness you can't feel it so that that
gentle release of the pelvic floor to
the breath awakens the ground of your
being and here's the interesting thing
were you know we're taught to breathe
with the thoracic diaphragm and that
works fine but it'll it'll move and
breathe and the pelvic floor can be
absolutely clenched and immobilized
if the pelvic floor releases the
thoracic diaphragm has to release so
it's inclusive and in fact it as the
pelvic floor releases to the in-breath
it invites the whole of the body to
purchase it right so the pelvic floor
supports the out-breath and it slightly
domes up into the end of the body and
then from that engaged place it just
releases and when it releases there's a
sense of the breath filling the body
from the bottom up rather than the top
down so it's like the pelvic floor opens
to the breath and the breath lands there
and fills the body from the bottom up
and you're not muscling the in-breath
you're not muscling the out-breath the
body's releasing too
well that's a whole mess of cotton balls
yeah yeah like to work through that and
that's the back that's a lower back and
that's the the pelvic floor that's where
our you know our legs are connected and
this is this is so many things the
source muscles this is this is an insane
amount of of even our the central
nervous system this is this is this is
an extremely important part of our
bodies and we are sitting and passing so
much time on the devices and that's
again this this shallow breath in the
head over and over again on the devices
so I'm looking so that's that's a huge
and when and and when you feel that
release of the pelvic floor to the
in-breath there is this wave of it's
like this massage for all the viscera
and you know stomach problems intestinal
problems are going to chronic in our
culture and if people could allow the
breath into there and allow that life it
finally you know the the digestion could
release into its own intelligence and
and be free to do what it knows to do
yeah
okay and then continue yes sense of the
exercise that the back the back has this
phenomenal capacity for breath but the
back is like there are these axes in the
body that for me fall along a
male-female polarity so we know about
like right brain to the left hand left
brain to the right hand and and you know
the right side tends to be dominant the
left side tends to be sensitive to the
whole and we demean the left we force
people who are left-handed to right with
the right we call the left sinister and
left sinister actually means left
there's this polarity between the
cranial brain and that brain in the
pelvic Bowl that we
about where this is analytical and
systematic and and gains perspectival
you gain perspective by stepping back
and creating distance so if this holds
us at a distance from the world and this
other brain comes into felt relationship
and the tombs to wholeness and then
there's this polarity between front and
back in our culture we're all about the
front and that's like the male part of
our sensitivity and the back there is
mystery at the back there is this
support the whole of your life in a
sense is present there ready to help you
take the next step but in each of those
cases where there's a polarity between a
male sensitivity and a female
we have demeaned and shut down and
neglected the female sensitivity we have
to mean the left side of the body
we've demean the intelligence in the
pelvic pool and we've lost the back
we've lost the breath in the back so I
can talk from my front and this is how I
sound if I do and there's no breath
going into my Baha and then I allow the
breath into my back and everything
changes and when I when I'm taking the
breath into the front of my body it's as
though there's a barrier going up
between me and the world I can funeral I
bring the breath into my front it's like
I'm separate from the world when I bring
the breath into my back it's like it's
like an embrace it's like inclusive it's
such a different quality yeah and you
undiscovered these through your own
experience was my own experience or
wisdom and I studied voice with a really
brilliant voice teacher yeah yeah you
very powerful voice yeah I love it I
love it so much yeah it's beautiful it's
one of my favorite voices I love it I
love it well then I should mention that
I radical wholeness is there's an audio
book and I do
I read good yeah I loved that someone
yeah yeah and give us the quick rest and
good so rest our culture says up is good
down as
that you're linking up she's looking a
little down today everything is about
heaven is up hell is down right so you
want to be in the head you don't want to
be down so what happens is we we you
know I was talking about how any energy
held in the body is a form of resistance
to the present
well our energy is held up in the body
it's disconnected from the earth and
it's such a different thing to let that
energy settle it's like there's an
exercise I do that allows that energy to
melt in the body and you feel it trickle
down to the soles of your feet and fill
the legs and fill the pelvic Bowl so
there's this spaciousness above it and
this grounded presence below it and the
other part of rest is we've got this
idea that thinking only happens in the
head but other cultures think from the
heart other cultures I think from the
belly so so how to let this frantic
not've of of thinking drop down and come
to rest on the pelvic floor so you can
you can feel the world from the pelvic
floor you can you can feel the sounds of
the world in the sites of the world yeah
from there and that is a radically
different yeah so you're moving from an
abstract realm that knows only bits and
pieces that knows only how to analyze
and pull things apart into a realm that
it Tunes to hold us and the world feels
different and your place in it feels
different it's beautiful feeling the
world from the body rather than the
brain yeah yeah so I mean a lot of
embodiment work is about listening to
the body and and that's I mean that's
valuable but it's not embodiment
embodiment is about listening to the
world through the body yeah it's running
interesting yeah
um do we wanna hit on the last two as
well relativity yep there is an
equivalence between recip tivity and
presidents so we're trying to be present
how do you do how do you be press well
if I'm fully receptive to you I'm fully
present to you so then you realize in
our culture there is no there is no
place there's no time where we're
allowed to just receive and so to move
for a whole morning into rest activity
is to find another Avenue through which
you explore presence and it's so easy to
just sit and receive and by doing so you
ground yourself in your own presence
interesting and then integration there's
so many exercises that that for example
you can take an idea in the head and
feel how it feels in the head and you
can drop that idea your eyes and allow
to come to rest on the pelvic floor and
it it is reborn as a sensitivity the
idea the flowers read is reborn as a
felt experience as it lands on the
pelvic floor and why does that matter
because sensitivity is the foundation of
our intelligence and as long as you're
running the show with unintegrated ideas
you are you're not you cannot live
intelligent me yeah
grounded sensitivity is intelligence
yeah I love what you've taught us about
the body I love what you've taught us
about grounded sensitivity being
intelligence and about your story that
your journey that got you to the to this
point of teaching this and it's it's so
powerful Phillip I want to ask you one
question that we typically ask at least
this question is one of my favorite
wants to ask is what is the most
beautiful thing in the world
what comes to my mind is forgiveness
that heart-opening that that incredible
dissolving of some hurt
it's a wonderful question
and if there were more forgiveness in
the world the world would be a very
different place yeah mmm
fill up Wow this has been so nice it's
been such a treat oh yeah he's so much
fun thank you thank you thank you I I
will never be able to walk the same
again I will always be doing my best to
train myself to feel the earth as I'm as
I'm walking as I'm standing as I'm
laying always always feeling the earth
there was this incredible at Transtech
there was this incredible just bed of
metallic plates that had a random number
generator vibrating the plates and you
were just laying on the bed so it's
simulated the Earth's vibration and
energy it was so cool the body just went
like this is home oh I'm so cool oh it's
so cool and so these are the future
technologies that we compare together
with things like yeah I'm I'm looking
I'm looking forward to what to what this
is gonna look like in the next couple of
years as these youths come into play as
well oh yeah with their intelligence oh
yeah they're their refashioning the
world grounded its sensitivity in the
body I have a lot to practice and I
thank you so much Philip this has been
such a pleasure Wow
thank you thank you your voice is
beautiful your body is beautiful thank
you thank you thank you thank you thank
you everybody for tuning and this has
been such a treat
we'd love to hear from you in the
comments below let us know what your
thoughts were on this episode also
definitely check out Philips books their
links are in the bio go check them out
check out his website check out his
workshops and let's get to
ground insensitivity together thank you
Ron for producing and directing much
love to you and happy birthday there you
go so much love so much love and join us
support us we're trying to scale our
efforts join us patreon cryptocurrency
are below much love everyone and we will
see you soon
[Music]
[Music]